* fröhliche Musik *
Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen
sind die häufigsten Todesursachen
in der westlichen Welt.
Hä, ich dachte,
das wird ein schönes Urlaubs-Video.
Ja, ja, dazu kommen wir gleich.
Jedenfalls:
Neben genetischen Faktoren
steigt das Risiko
für Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen
durch schlechte Ernährung,
einen Mangel an Bewegung...
Ich bin im Urlaub!
...und Rauchen.
* Feuerzeug ratscht. *
Doch ein Faktor,
der gerne übersehen wird, ist Stress.
Sag ich doch.
Die Deutschen haben den Ruf,
besonders fleißig
und effizient zu sein.
Dabei ist Deutschland, was
die Urlaubstage pro Jahr betrifft,
mit 27 Tagen/Schnitt weltweit weit
vorne mit dabei. Das ist gut so.
Denn Stress,
Überstunden und die Unfähigkeit,
in der Freizeit
von der Arbeit abzuschalten,
sind nicht nur körperlich ungesund,
sondern verschlechtern
auch Engagement
und Motivation der Arbeitnehmer.
Gut zu wissen ist,
dass Dutzende Studien
weltweit wissenschaftlich belegen,
dass Urlaub gesund ist.
Man fand folgende Zusammenhänge:
Menschen, die über Jahre
mehr als 8 Stunden/Tag arbeiten,
haben eine bis
zu 40 % erhöhte Wahrscheinlichkeit
für eine koronare Herzerkrankungen,
also eine Verhärtung
der Herzkranzgefäße.
Menschen, die über Jahre
keinen oder nur kurzen Urlaub nehmen,
zeigen eine um 30% erhöhte
Herzinfarkt-Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Und die psychische Gesundheit,
die nicht selten
mit der Leistungsfähigkeit
auf der Arbeit korreliert,
wurde in vielen Studien untersucht.
Durch Urlaub können Gefahr für
Burnout oder Depression verringert
und kognitive Fitness erhöht werden.
Es wurde aber auch beobachtet, dass
die positiven Effekte nach dem Urlaub
schnell wieder
dem Arbeitsalltag weichen.
Soll man das Urlauben
also gleich lassen?
Um die Psychologin Jessica de Bloom
zu zitieren:
"Das wäre, als würde man fragen:
Warum schlafen wir, obwohl wir
sowieso wieder müde werden?"
Mein Fazit ist:
viel Schlafen und viel Urlaub.
Liebe Grüße aus Italien.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
* Meeresrauschen
und fröhliche Musik *